happy wednesday everyone but
unfortunately the steam deck has been
delayed however we did get a new trailer
for the skyrim anniversary edition and
more i'm persia and this is your
gamespot news
it was announced on the steam website
that the launch of the steam deck will
be delayed by two months steem said in a
statement we're sorry about this we did
our best to work around the global
supply chain issues but due to material
shortages components aren't reaching our
manufacturing facilities in time for us
to meet our initial launch dates and
based on estimates it looks like the
steam deck won't be shipping to
customers until february of 2022 this
will also be the new start date of the
reservation queue but if you already had
a reservation then your date will just
be shifting back accordingly the
statement also said that reservation
date estimates will be updated shortly
so if you want to view your updated
expected order availability then you'll
have to visit store.steampowered.com
steamdeck
skyrim is celebrating its 10th
anniversary and bethesda is re-releasing
the game once again with an anniversary
edition a new trailer for the game has
now arrived ahead of the game's launch
on november 11th showcasing what's
included in the bundle and it's a lot
the anniversary edition comes with the
base game the three major expansions
dawnguard hearthfire and dragonborn as
well as new gear and magic systems
fishing is included as well additionally
all creation club content is featured in
the re-release the anniversary edition
costs 50 us dollars but people who own
the skyrim special edition can upgrade
for 20 bucks if you happen to already
have the special edition well then you
can get the ps5 and xbox series x and s
enhancements for free this includes
enhanced graphics faster loading times
and more
with battlefield 2042's release coming
up very soon dice has shared some more
details on what you can expect in terms
of post launch support some might have
been expecting this information sooner
but a new blog post confirms that the
information will be announced early in
2022 so at launch players will be taking
part in a pre-season instead of a proper
season one in the preseason players will
find weekly missions and rewards as well
as limited time modes and curated
content from the battlefield portal
which is live right now battlefield
portal is a new platform within
battlefield 2042 that will let you
create and find experiences made by the
community give you access to settings
custom modes and a logic editor and more
when season one does arrive it will add
a new specialist of the battle pass more
portal content and maybe even some new
sites to see dice teased it was also
stated that launch is only the beginning
and dice is taking a new approach to
live service with not only a commitment
to new content but a goal of enhancing
the battlefield experience through
seasons that will continue to evolve the
world of battlefield 2042
now if we think a little bit more big
picture battlefield 2042's first year of
live service will include four seasons
four battle passes four new specialists
and new locations to explore battlefield
portal will get its own set of separate
live service updates over time as well
so buckle up battlefield fans it looks
like there's no shortage of content on
the way pokemon brilliant diamond and
shining pearl remakes of the 2006
classics will get a day 1 update the
patch will update the game to version
1.1.0 and nintendo recommends
downloading it before starting the game
it will require three gigs of space if
you downloaded the game from the
nintendo eshop you won't need to
download a separate update according to
the patch notes the update adds online
communication features for grand
underground super contest show in union
room and it allows you to receive gifts
using the mystery gift feature it also
adds more playable content like ramanus
park that opens up after you enter the
hall of fame adds more in-game cutscenes
and animations and even includes various
bug fixes the patch notes also tease
another update to come some time after
release which will increase the maximum
number of players who can battle and
trade in the union room as well as gws
training in jubalife city and the
coliseum future in pokemon centers for
the full list of patch notes be sure to
visit gamespot.com and if you've been
wondering what other new games or
content you can expect this year then
get ready for the game awards new
details were shared for the show that
will be held on december 9th with to 50
games being showcased in some capacity
with a double-digit number of those
games being new reveals
what is your dream game that you would
love to see revealed at the show let me
know in the comments and be sure to
subscribe to our channel because we'll
also be broadcasting the game awards
right here on december 9th thank you all
so much for watching and we'll catch you
next time
[Music]
you